now what I've given you here like this
is the concise version the question
itself if you have a look at the papers
you've got it bad he brought it with you
it gives you some clues that some hints
which make the question a long time okay
so for part one what they say is to get
this their clue for you is go back to
first principles that's a good clue okay
so first principles let's just remember
it looks like this you've still got the
same limit up there
there you go a fraction it's rise over
run recite repeat what is the first
principle structure f of X plus h minus
f of X all over H Shaco rise over run
okay now then you have to get to this
okay so clearly you can see there's an e
involved right you have to work out what
the derivative for is at zero you see
that if I meant X equal zero right
that's going to make this another day
and you see what's gonna happen okay so
let's consider for okay so f dash will
equal as H approaches zero no dramas so
far okay now by the way one of the
reasons why this doesn't tend to appear
in like your early and limits questions
is because unlike say a polynomial or
even something with a square root right
it's it's difficult to how do you
resolve this how do you how do you
cancel that age on the bottom is there's
a simple algebraic fix you can use to do
that so instead we're going to appeal to
this we want to say well how about this
particular value all right you put in
zero right this is going to get us up to
here okay so at x equals zero right this
will be e to the 0 which is 1 okay so
you get to this right now then you think
okay well that's the right hand side
done
but I don't know like this is what I'm
trying to find out right so baby that
there's nothing algebraic more you can
do right you sort of hit the end of the
line where else could you look in order
to get a value for this I'm very
deliberately telling you like from this
point like this there's no more you
can't do anything to that okay so you
must take another path what other parts
are open to you so when you hit a dead
end right the natural thing is turn
around and look back and see what you've
got here I think the most important
thing is remember what is this function
it's e to the X right and we're
considering the derivative of this of
this function at a particular point but
but you know what the derivative of e to
the X is right the derivative of e to
the X is e to the X right
that's if - right so therefore F - 0
should be this with x equals 0 right
which is which is 1 ok so this is just
like how we approach that on that proof
of the binomial theorem right you're
like you do something you get to one
point okay it's like well can I get to
this through another way and the entries
as you can okay so therefore this thing
this limit right if - zero that's equal
to one bingo is your answer